elle devait passer sa vie devant un
tableau hélène benguigui a choisi de
passer ses journées derrière les
fourneaux
au lieu de tenter le capes de français
il ya une dizaine d'années elle se
tourne vers la cuisine
j'avais envie de faire ça depuis
longtemps et si je devenais professeur
il y aurait pas eu de retour n'est
impossible
donc c'est le moment ou jamais c'était
une année à perdre si jamais je me
trompais et puissant aurait que je n'ai
pas perdu cette année finalement elle
obtient son ca paix à 22 ans
puis elle travaille dans des restaurants
étoilés de la région parisienne mais
c'est bien la cuisine de grand-mère
qu'elle affectionne particulièrement
c'est la cuisine de l'émotion c'est la
cuisine la cuisine devrait en fin de
compte la cuisine authentique
après je m'amuse beaucoup à la
retravailler avec des épices deserves
j'essaye vraiment de réinventer avec un
côté plus moderne et créatif mais la
base de cette cuisine c'est
l'authenticité
un credo qu'hélène benguigui applique
dans son établissement à gien le café
bouche bée elle l'a ouvert il ya un an
et demi avec son associé déjà on s'est
rapprochés par d'apparat des valeurs
communes et une envie de créer
lieu convivial
sur des bases de 2
relations avec nos petits producteurs
pour ce concours de la meilleure recette
régionale hélène a choisi en dessert la
tarte tatin originaire de sologne et le
pâté de pâques spécialité berrichonne
c'est un plat qui est à ces paysans et
rustique et donc j'ai vraiment réfléchi
pour tâcher de le rendre plus moderne et
sans trop le dénaturer parce qu'en fin
de compte c'est un plat qui rappelle
beaucoup de souvenirs dans beaucoup de
familles et il fallait pas que je
m'éloigne de trop de la recette
originale tout en la rendant original
justement elle n'en dira pas plus pour
admirer le résultat
rendez vous ce vendredi soir sur france